happy Halloween everybody clap it up
what are you doing Halloween you clap
that's right happy Halloween
this we're gonna have to be honest now
myself yeah it's time to get real yeah
it's the second time we shoot this video
yeah but we shot these like it was a
long time ago and then I figured out we
weren't recording the audio and I was
just like damn but here we are again and
we're here to talk about houses so you
found this film it's a Japanese horror
film we you show me the trailer and then
he looks insane
the movie looks insane and I'm very
excited to show it to you guys
together with MRSA which showed it to me
so it was made by no Behe kobayashi and
his direction for making this film was
that it was good the Japanese version of
Jaws
you know jaws the moment the shark yeah
that was the direction that he got from
the studio they were like let make us a
movie like jaws really yeah which
doesn't really make any sense now I see
it did really well in Japan they didn't
think it would do well but their reviews
were terrible but then they didn't
understand me well the thing with house
is that it might seem like a really bad
movie it's not it's a bad good movie but
not it's so bad it's good it's just it's
bad but it's still good
[Laughter]
oh okay so she kept on school that's her
then you love this scene a companion
that's what you say when you bring on
the new wife come out
[Music]
all these she gets it oh yeah that we
known the effect she looks like layer
from Star Wars
[Music]
oh yeah that's how you know you're
killing it so her name is actually
gorgeous yeah oh this this story is
actually about seven girls right so I
don't know we'll see them all later yeah
they all are just named after their
personality mm-hmm it's great
sayers when they introduced all the
girls in the movie and it gets really
weird it's just this guy my god how do
we explain this to people well they are
having it's summertime so they are all
gonna go on volume together
this is the Ben
that's how you fall right yes oh wow how
did that happen me show me whenever I
fell down the stairs
I love the background that I clearly
just like sets Lord wrongs or whatever
yeah so funny
this is seemed like a horror movie yet
yeah
why is her backdrop on it back dry they
were clearly just like having a laugh
making this film like yeah they tell you
all the names now right melody professor
sweet as skin comfort spring Mac after
Big Mac probably yeah so none of the
girls were actual like actresses not
real one like not really like upcoming
maybe or like okay
what why actually we need to get them in
the mood was he would play the music on
set so I think that's why it's so
bombarded by music all the time but it
kind of work like they don't seem that
bad but apparently like everyone that
worked on it were like that they're
terrible you know it's not real it's
just a backdrop against making sure
what in the world I think it was a bird
but I don't some wanted us to win hey
[Music]
this is how you act by the way everyone
does this right and comfor gets attack
this must be so confusing but I'm
confused if you think this is confusing
she's standing me there this is
ridiculous so a lot of the stuff that
they did the special effects and the
things they don't make any sense
apparently he asked his daughter for
advice during the film hmm because he
thought it would give another
perspective to stuff that grown-ups
don't think about so they made
special-effects kind of reflective of
that as well they did they made a
special thanks trying to make them look
bad but it also just seemed like
something you would say afterwards like
yeah we just we didn't made the effects
to make them look bad it's it's yeah
wait so her mom used to live there so
this is sort of the me oh she sees her
mom and think
[Music]
and after this scene is when it goes
apeshit I would say yes when he starts
[Music]
mom today gray can we get to the good
bit she's getting killed by a mattress
by the way this one just want to make
sure my mattress now well not the
pillows anything but how should we kill
this girl
the peelers get the pillows I think they
just wanted the panty shot
[Music]
oh my God look at that any brighter by
ten out of ten Oh Sergei oh my god why
is it so a low framerate what in the
world
no this is they actually not messing up
it's this low framerate for no reason I
think it's supposed to be like a style
style is like it's very annoying okay so
all the girls pretty much died spoilers
and they all died in the best way ever
we have the mattress we have the bit but
I think this is one of the best one I
can Betsy and then conclude yeah
when the music is too good and you can't
stop playing oh yeah there's a skeleton
in the back oh my god and they're the
goldfish oh wow
yep that's oh wow oh wow
[Music]
we again we were looking at a girl
getting eaten by a camera through a
fishbowl that's the level of it I feel
like this is one of those things where
they just tell them like I don't wanna
buy it's going it's going to look really
great after the effects are in don't
worry about it what's this yeah so
apparently they use my blue paint for
everything so they could just chroma key
but clearly you see the blue
[Music]
I saw it as sort of like a copy of The
Shining you know how the guy just knows
that he has to save the kid or whatever
there's a sin but yeah for some reason
yeah this one guy just realizes I'm
gonna go save them yeah maybe we didn't
get it though maybe we miss you maybe my
own
[Music]
I don't
Memphis is telling me this in Japan
[Music]
oh wow what how waves what was that that
door dishes are coming for as well
[Music]
that's the guy I'm trying to save them
trying real hard my god the cat is so
cool this shut my god
what is happening
[Music]
how's your back the cat destroy it of
course oh no oh yeah she gets sucked
into the plan what is
happening for the land most the lamb
gets hurt
of course we get the mattress the well
[Music]
the lamb
see I was just getting eaten by the land
are you interested in this film this is
compelling to you
wait but comfor comes back with her legs
to kick that wow wow oh my god oh wow oh
my god it's like they asked himself how
many special effects can we fit in this
three second segment our professors dead
too bad she couldn't find her glasses
what it's very strange
[Music]
but it's not being yet
that's heightened yes eimai oh wow I
guess they like it cut huh
well that was how soon great in film I
think is actually really good I'll be
pleased keeping through like these this
is confusing because it's confusing than
just watching them but that's part of it
you know if you get a bunch of friends
oh yeah it's a good time to watch for
Halloween and that's why it's on
Halloween mmm-hmm and if you appreciate
the aesthetic of the film like we do
so apparently or by actually before he
was working on this film he was working
on another project so it sort that
product even though he was asked to take
naked jaws he was working on this kind
of serious project and he kind of
brought that into this film and I we
didn't notice it at all the first time
we watched it at all I think probably
the message behind the film goes beyond
your hand or whatever but apparently if
I actually grew up in Hiroshima which
was the city that got bombed from world
war ii and he lost all his friends they
all his family and childhood friends who
were gone so he wanted to make a movie
that described that losing everyone and
I think he wanted to do it in a comedic
way because it was too bizarre to
comprehend yeah in any other fashion
even though it seems really silly how
she get eaten by a piano thank you for
letting me share this film with you
Mertz and to have a great Halloween
everybody also buy my merch it's limited
link in the description stop touching my
nipple because I respect you mind see
that's why